yeah he thinks he's the king of trivia
he's better than me at trivia trivia
let's reveal pursued any of those games
I think I could give you a run I won't I
don't think I'm better than you would
anything anymore
you know you get the Trivial Pursuit
game that Robin pick five questions
randomly you ask me a question and let's
say I get it okay okay then you ask him
a new question key and even if I get
when I'm wrong you ask him a fresh
question fine
all right answer your question no five
questions wrong you want to do it that
way you want to answer mine or I get to
answer your somebody should have the
opportunity because then you get to
prove you know that you got a coin flip
a coin for who goes first call it in the
air both heads heads it is
alright I'll go first alright I actually
get to choose because I have heads I
want Gary to go first oh do I get to do
it's any category any category don't
even judge the category just whatever
your eye goes we should know what the
category is because oh you can know what
it is when she announces it right okay
entertainment okay what was the first
talking motion picture with sound on the
film that would be the jazz singer I
didn't even know that I thought it was
like the Great Train Robbery but I know
it's a silent film see I do bad at this
maybe the kindest should be somebody
keeps going till they no no you wanna
you wanna it's not a contest then go
ahead what type of bedding is used in
horse racing there's a name for it yeah
it's like parlor bedding there is a name
for let me think I know there's
off-track betting how much time does it
yet I know there's okay I'll go with
parlor betting now what I can answer
that Robin go ahead it's paramutual bet
good happy I'm in trouble guess you're
not that stupid before I work for you
when I was real only guy I started
before I go to bed at night I would just
read the cards really you might die just
to mention that on the air one day you
did a whole rap about power mutual
betting yeah but any call it paramutual
betting I don't retain all right that's
2 to nothing Baba Booey you go Baba
Booey who's keeping score somebody keep
score might have to change my name to
Baba blue it's Gary's quick knocking and
my dad yelling to me you don't know
paramutual betting yeah cuz Gary just
answered your questions I says turn
again that's right what's the former
name of John F Kennedy Airport no he'll
hold on a second I don't idle why hmm
idle wipe out of wine Idlewild you're
right two to one
hey I'm coming up getting nervous pretty
bad for a while you were pretty close
though what future Georgia he didn't
have those big teeth he would have got
Georgia governor chase three blacks from
his diner in 1964 that would be George
Wallace no it is not let's say he was
Alabama what was he thinking oh that
would be Jimmy Carter that is wrong okay
now since I got that wrong and I went
first I think Gary goes first this time
Gary it's Gary's question what's the
score - one two - one
thank you feel to the one thank god
what's the subject rather we could be
here all day American literature what
writer was nicknamed Poppa Ernest
Hemingway yeah that's right
here's what I know Papa Hemingway I knew
that what building built in 1897
contains 327 miles of bookshelves Wow I
know that you know it mmm Oh could you
repeat the question
I got a stall for time building built in
1897
contains 327 miles of book
well it's gotta be some kind of library
very good man I would have to say it's
gotta be in New York or Washington or
something like this I'm gonna say what's
that there Museum over there Washington
Pony and that's what I got to say
Library of Congress it's a library
what's the biggest I can't I can't like
kick the ball through the field goal but
you you had it I had it too it's a
library damn I was closer I should get
points where's it for one now what
question what was the infamous pseudonym
of William Bonney Oh
oh come on it's a no brainer of William
Bonney oh that's not fair how come he
gets the easy ones
he can't easily shut up Clyde Barrow
[Music]
give me one now I go first make it easy
go ahead I cleaned like a white tornado
oh come on I'm not even gonna take that
Ajax no brainer for two got some boy
don't look that embarrassing anymore all
right Bob slowly now put me away
American literature what is the name of
Superman's dog oh wait I don't think he
knows it I know Krypto
for three baby I'm not a super douche -
crypto man it's a no-brainer what's
American who now Howard Howard crypto
this is a science question good
what do gorillas do when they get
nervous I know they don't listen to
Jackie's tape I know what they do what
they pee wrong what do you say Gary you
know this well that's right who goes
first this time that was your question
don't you feel like I got a pee when you
nervous whenever I'm with a girl for the
first time I feel like I got a pee you
compare yourself to a gorilla yeah where
does the same thing all right
you think we're that different 43 what
was the first Apollo mission to orbit
the moon well that's not fair the first
Apollo mission to orbit the moon I
believe was Apollo 7 that's right Apollo
I go what I didn't see your mouth let me
say it Apollo 7 is wrong yes so I get a
shot so basically I know it's not Apollo
13 because I saw the movie and they
weren't the first I don't know if it was
an Apollo 12 I never heard of one what
did you say Apollo 7 Paolo eight you're
such a right let's disqualify that girl
come on you really are the world's
greatest lawyer I love you you really
I'm not lying I don't see what I do that
and you are so I just said I'll go up
one from you you seem to know stuff no
way if I win I still lose I got wrong
the Mystery of Edwin Drood unfinished
that's so easy
[Laughter]
Krypto
Rupert Holmes why don't you let me get a
guess there's your turn
what's the question easy Edgar Allan Poe
what am I doing with you to Charles
Dickens loser did he write any Superman
episodes let me get Howard yeah I go
first I really want to ready really for
for tell me whatever my didn't break the
rules
whatever my eye fell on good what film
featured the characters Charlie Allnut
and Rosie Sayer I don't know if you know
this but I'm gonna say Charlie all night
and Rosie Sayer that sounds like one of
those goddamn police academy movies I'm
gonna say police academy 5 Charlie Alma
and Rosie sayeth I don't know charlie
know what Charlie Chan do you know jack
what is it this is obscure Katharine
Hepburn impression of shaking check you
stood up started shaking whose question
mine pop-up holy to destroy Pompeii hmm
well I got this one
Mount Vesuvius yeah yeah see
Safia he wins five dreaming well it's
5-3 I win I'll give you two questions my
time yes you can make it five five mind
you be fair about and say the real score
5-4 and I get my last question to see if
I can tie it up you know I got a hollow
eight given the point it's five four
that's it it's five of them for sure the
first kennedy-nixon TV debate that would
be I know this too it's Howard K Smith
let's see I don't even know I have a
guess skinny guy looks like it's cancer
I don't even know I come through in the
clutch man I'm stirring cuz like anybody
who can win this game ripped off retains
no no Gary I'll tell you Robin mouthed
the words thank you alright
Howard K Smith man that's the dude ready
yeah I'm ready
what US city was called the birthplace
of a skyscraper how that would be New
York that would be wrong
do you have an in birthplace of the
skyscraper Robin no-brainer I know it's
not Babel what state you're asking me
what city what city was the birthplace
of the sky Scranton see I could go with
it's gotta be one of them cities that
was an early city and I can't be like
Philadelphia can't be Los Angeles can be
zan Francisco maybe could be San
Francisco that's one of the mold cities
but that was out in the Wild West could
be Washington for Christ's sake see now
I know the answer I'm gonna say Chicago
that's the outside Chicago I told you I
never win